Rachel starts us off this hour in Boise
Idaho
hi Rachel how are you hi Dave good
thanks for taking my call
sure welcome out okay where do I start
my husband has about 160 thousand
dollars in student loan debt and this is
that that or loans that his mom signed
him up for when he started college and
still about nine months ago that his
parents approached us and told us that
that there was another loan that Ben had
taken out but had put it in their name
since they had maxed out the amount that
they could put in my husband's name and
it's ninety thousand dollars it had
started at sixty thousand but they let
it sit there without telling us and
without making payment so it accrued
about thirty thousand dollars so my
question is what do we do with that do
we try to get the loan in our name
somehow do we tell them that we'll pay
them back once we're done paying loans
in our name
I don't know so to say that his parents
are financially idiots is an
understatement
and I assume they're broke mm-hmm god
that's so maddening
you sound so sweet would not have been
sweet oh by the way ninety thousand
dollars it's in mine it's in their name
right yes yeah and they are broke I
assume yes they don't act like they are
but you know they are they spend money
like crazy like they're in Congress okay
what do you think their household income
would be if you were to guess I guess
anywhere from 150 to 200 and what is
your household income our household
income is 55 mm-hmm okay is your husband
intimate
by them no I would say he he doesn't
want to hurt them especially his mom
mm-hmm I wouldn't say intimidated okay I
don't want to hurt them I didn't set out
to hurt them they have hurt themselves
and they're asking you who make a third
of what they make to take care of them
mm-hmm it's kind of absurd mm-hmm they
made the choice to take out a loan in
their name how many years ago did your
husband go to college he graduated in
2013 okay and so four years after
graduation five six seven years after
they take this loan out they decide to
do the big reveal mm-hmm you got married
to him having no idea this existed they
failed to mention it then they failed to
mention it to him when he was in school
and now this couple that makes 150 or
200 s coming to a couple making 65 and
asking you to pick up their mess mm-hmm
am I missing something
no so you know the answer that Sharron
and I would give were we in your
situation is Mom and Dad we got enough
on our plate and this is a mistake you
made we're really sorry you made this
mistake but good luck with it
okay I wouldn't pay it oh they have more
ability to pay than you they made the
decision without your input or your
husband's input they kept it from you
that it existed
they've mishandled it there's like 63
checks on the wrong side of the boxes
here mm-hmm
the only thing that reason I hear in
here for you to pay it is your husband
doesn't want his mommy to feel bad where
do you see a reason you should pay this
I I guess we just kind of feel worse we
were feel responsible because it's had
your husband agreed to this deal known
about this deal had you agreed to this
deal and known about this deal when you
married into this mess yeah I would feel
responsible I don't know why do you feel
responsible I know I don't feel
responsible for it and I didn't know
about it until just now
okay I think this lady is a travel agent
for guilt trips is this relationship
with them a little toxic otherwise well
very they are enablers with all with my
husband and all his siblings but we have
a pretty good relationship but there's
always this kind of this awkward
situation because of these loans and you
know they're paying them and so it's we
have an okay relationship with them but
this it does make it pretty awkward yeah
they're not paying them mm-hmm we need
to keep that in mind
yeah it's $90,000 not 60,000 they're not
paying them yeah they've been not paying
them for a while so so far so far it
hasn't actually done any damage to them
it will eventually yeah so I I just I
think there's all kinds of boundary
violations here and I I mean I know it's
going to put a strain on your
relationship now if you if if you told
me you made five hundred thousand
dollars a year and you wanted to do this
after you got your stuff cleaned up and
these people made thirty five thousand
dollars a year and you want to do this
after you got your stuff cleaned up I
might say okay but the roles are
somewhat reversed here yeah you know
they're asking the responsible people
who make a third of their income to take
care of their mistake that you were
never informed of and oh and by the way
we're up to two hundred thousand dollars
for your husband's education here that's
stupid land it's just nuts for broke
people and so chief man so I think I'd
get the book boundaries and read it
because I think you and your husband are
going to struggle a lot more
with this conversation than I would it
wouldn't I mean I I'm not mad about it
but I'm just not doing it it's just kind
of ridiculous there's nothing in this
conversation that sounds healthy to me
so but it may in Maine you know in the
the lack of health emotional mental
health and neural family relationship
the toxicity may rise to the top when
you finally do say you know I don't feel
obligated for this because you're not
legally obligated we know that are you
morally obligated mmm
maybe only if we went all the way back
and your husband said yeah mommy I'll do
whatever you want take out as much dad
as you want take out and I'll pay for it
no matter what and then when he got
married dear he said honey I got a whole
bunch of that I got something over here
mom and dad got some over there
that's what you're marrying into then
yeah maybe then it was part of the deal
but you can't just kind of I mean what
are they gonna come up with next year
how often are they gonna bring one of
these up oh by the way forgot about this
to remember that car I bought you back
when you're 16 you got to pay for that
too I forgot about that oh and what
about this you know where does it stop
it's just weird that weird this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
you
[Music]